[Musik]
die inflation ist da und sie haben
trotzdem nichts besseres zu tun als mich
zu treffen heißt das sie haben schon
resigniert nein ich bin noch vollkommen
dabei wir haben momentan die
inflationsrate 1,3 1,4 prozent die läuft
dies ist ja auf 1,9 prozent die ezb hat
mit zielgröße von zwei prozent also
alles im normalen rahmen der muss sich
das gespenst nicht aus der tonne holen
sie sind so optimistisch sie sind so
beschränkt sie letztes jahr haben wir
deflation gehabt aber an alle am
schreien jetzt haben wir inflation dazu
kommt ja noch das andere gespenst zinsen
zinsen zinsen ja wo sollen sie denn
herkommen wenn wir jetzt in europa die
zinsen erhöhen
da können die italiener ihre schulden
nicht mehr bezahlen geht nicht wie hoch
wird die inflationsrate werden was
glauben sie
das kann ihn keiner sagen inflationsrate
würde etwas in diesem jahr etwas
ansteigen weil ich jetzt auch drei
prozent gibt es noch 1 4 prozent wieder
zurückgehen und im zweiten hälfte des
erzählen sich was über werden es ist
nicht so hoch noah spielt gar keine
rolle weil schon bei zwei prozent
inflation halbiert sich ihr vermögen 20
jahren und so oder so sollte die
deutschen sich einfach darum kümmern
dass ihr geld besser anlegen
es ist hier recht investieren wo wir ein
er ist ihr hobby hört sich jetzt echt
super
die basics online-broker ok und dann
direkt etf sparplan genau so weiß nicht
mehr was das ist worüber redet du kannst
ihnen eine einzelne songs oder alben
investieren ja oder benutzt das ganze
album das ist schon alles songs drin ja
dann bitte das sind bezeugt auf jeden
song partei ok top erklärung besser kann
man es nicht sagt ich habe in einem
monaten gespräch mit meiner neuen bank
kommt mir geht es um eine konservative
geldanlage die inflation bekämpfen
was wäre das ja also am besten
irgendwelche werte die die drinnen
stehen kann müssen dass werte seien
hinter dem hand steht da geht es auch um
geld verdienen oder erstmal schauen
heute dazu suchen wo kommst du denn was
für werte
es geht um kohle wer sind sie eigentlich
ich bin nicht auf an der börse
was man dort kopp und du bist ja
finden sie den seriösen mit knauf was
sagen sie den leuten die sie als
unseriös empfinden die mich als unsicher
empfinden thunfisch der held 20 jahre
da bin ich schon längst über die wupper
ja dagegen immer da ist jetzt das
seerestaurant häufig der hält ewig und
drei tage schützt vor der inflation
[Gelächter]
was soll ich mit meiner kohle machen
also ich habe jetzt nicht so viel
erspartes ich bin selbstständiger
künstler bin eigentlich am arsch wenn
sie geld retten wollte schützen wollen
dann spart man dann global
diversifizierte anlegen aktienfonds
möglich kostengünstig nicht aus dem
bankberater hören nicht auf die
fernsehnachrichten hören ruhe bewahren
alles andere ist schlecht sie gibt den
schönen spruch hin und her macht taschen
leer
wir freuen uns darüber dass wir locker
und die stadt nicht zu ende sind dass
die menschen wieder konsumieren gehen
dementsprechend kommt die bisher die
kälte als meine favoriten zu nehmen xp
gadahn und eben auch am tag danach noch
teil doch sehr voll der streber weißt du
das eigentlich ist ihr system der
weintrinker sinnvoll der streber ist und
ich stehe hier wie ein dorf da dann wird
der beitrag so gestimmt dass ich wieder
dorfen tab mit seinem sparbuch dasteht
und hier kommt er mister superschlau und
erzählt ihr einen verkehr ja deswegen
finance ich habe keinen bock mache ich
aber nicht ich hatte das ist ja auch
nochmal scheiß beitragen das geld erst
zurück ins studio und ihr könnt die
streber scheiße alleine
[Musik]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da